in the 1860s there was a zoologist by
the name of Philip Slater who proposed
that there was a landmass that stretched
from Madagascar all the way to India
Slater suggested that such a landmass
could explain an apparent discrepancy in
the evolutionary tree of species found
in Africa and India his reasoning for
thinking this is that you can find
lemurs in Madagascar you can find lemurs
in India but not in Africa and
Madagascar is a lot closer to Africa
than India at some point in history
Madagascar in India had to be connected
by a giant landmass Sclater names the
lost landmass Lemuria several other
Victorian academics suggest that Lemuria
could even hold the key to one of the
greatest mysteries of human evolution
some scholars suggest that this lost
landmass is where we originated from
mankind this is where we came down from
the trees which is now what we call the
missing link
maybe all the evidence we need is on
Lemuria and it's this land bridge and
it's now buried underwater the missing
link in human evolution may just have
been found from space then on the island
of Mauritius comes another clue
[Music]
scientists go to Mauritius and scoop up
some sand and other soil and what they
found was something very surprising what
they found in those samples were sir
Khan's zircon crystals are minerals
created when continents first formed
during the Earth's turbulent geological
past the fact that you find certain
crystals on this young Island suggests
that there must be some kind of
continental crust that's beneath the
island geologists now believed that the
lost continent detected by the NASA
satellites was once part of an ancient
supercontinent
180 million years ago the giant landmass
began to break up creating Africa South
America Australia and Antarctica
apocalyptic tectonic forces pulled a
lost continent apart and submerge it
beneath the waves
when a continent breaks up entire
Earth's crust will just be ripped open
and leaves chunks of these continents to
stranded in the middle of nowhere
gravity mapping of the Earth's oceans is
revealing previously undiscovered parts
of the planet as to what else lies
beneath the waves we can only speculate
we now have the technology to apply what
we have found in this one particular
place to the entire globe this might be
the first of many more ancient
continents that we find beneath the
waves